en qué cuadrante se encuentra el punto
menos 77 ubicada vamos a revisar lo que
es un cuadrante un cuadrante es cada uno
de estos cuatro segmentos o secciones de
este plano coordenada hablamos de estas
secciones cómo están divididas por los
ejes este es el eje x y este eje
vertical es el eje y pueden ver que
divide en el plano ordenado en cuatro
secciones y a cada una de estas
secciones le llamamos cuadrante este de
acá donde el eje x y el eje tienen sus
valores positivos le llamamos el primer
cuadrante y lo indicamos con el número
romano 1 si nos movemos en sentido
antihorario este otro cuadrante donde
los valores del eje x son negativos pero
los valores del eje ya son positivos lo
llamamos el segundo cuadrante y usamos
el número romano 2 ya que se lo escribí
mejor lo pongo así y vamos al trabajo en
donde tanto los valores del eje x como
del eje son negativos le llamamos el
tercer cuadrante y sé que usamos el
número romano 3 para designarlo
valores del eje x son positivos y los
valores del eje son negativos pues va a
ser el cuarto cuadrante ahora veamos en
qué cuadrante está ubicado este punto
menos 77 pueden observar que tenemos un
valor x negativo ya que éste es negativo
tendremos que movernos o nuestro
cuadrante estará del lado izquierdo
estará de este lado en el plano por el
simple hecho de que tenemos un valor de
x negativa ahora sabemos que el valor
que es positivo por lo tanto va a estar
aquí arriba y cuando tenemos valores de
x negativos y valores de positivos el
cuadrante involucrado es el segundo el
número 2 otra forma de pensar en esto es
simplemente graficar este punto y ver en
qué cuadrante está vamos a hacerlo si x
es menos 7 vamos a desplazarnos 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 vamos a ver 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
ok si es aquí y tenemos que subir 7
cuadritos porque nuestra g es positiva y
vale 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 ahí está el punto
este es mi punto menos 77 y en efecto
está en el segundo cuadrante